The Joe Rogan Experience I think my
third day there was a
was was my birthday and uh you know
again just
I lived in a place called parkour Tory
which is Gorky Park it was kind of a a
pretty rough sort of shitty area in
Moscow and I had a translator yeah I
spoke no Russian at all when I first
went over there and uh my translator Max
came and picked me up where I was living
he took me to the Moscow Art Theater
which is on severskaya right across the
street from Red Square it's a few subway
stops in a couple different directions
to get there and once we got there the
one thing that they tell you that's
absolutely essential at all times you
always have to have your papers back
then at that point the the mayor ran the
Mafia the mayor's police they didn't
really have a salary they made their
money by what they could sort of shake
people down for so
we get to the theater
um you know on my birthday and uh my
first day of school and and I think like
I'm actually making something in my life
I'm here in Russia but me being the [ __ ]
up that I am I forgot my papers because
I'm just a just you know unadulterated
[ __ ] and I said to Max man I'm so
sorry man I forgot my papers you know
I'm uh and he said okay well we got to
go back and get them and I said no man
let's just go into school and and we'll
do it the next day he said no they're
not going to let you into the school
without your papers let's go back and
get them I said look man I'm a grown ass
man let me go back and get my papers you
don't have to come with me you just took
me here
so I convinced him to let me go by
myself and then again me being the
[ __ ] that I am and everything's in
Cyrillic I couldn't read anything I got
completely [ __ ] lost and I just had
no idea where I was I'm three days in
Russia
I'm I'm I'm it's getting dark I'm
screwing up I finally make it back to my
place I get my papers I make it back to
the school but now I've missed the first
day it's like completely dark and I'm on
the wrong side of tiverskaya which is
like this Main Street about 16 lanes and
I got to get to the other side to get to
school and I just start kind of like
like Frogger I'm like dodging cars like
a normal [ __ ] like I can't get to the
other side as soon as I get to the other
side boom
AK-47s in my face Russian police are
right there they get me for crossing
you're supposed to cross below I didn't
know that they're yelling at me in
Russian I give them you know 20 rubles
they let me go and I'm just like just
such an [ __ ] it's my birthday I've
missed my first day I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm doing and so I do what any
good American would do I'd go and treat
myself to a meal at McDonald's right so
I go and I get myself some McDonald's
Happy Birthday to me you're a [ __ ] up
right
then I'm going back that night and I'm
back in Parker tour and I'm walking down
the street I'm all by myself it's pitch
blackouts cold as [ __ ] and I'm walking
down the street and this Mercedes pulls
up in front of me and these two guys get
out of the front seat
and they reach into the back seat and
they grab something out and I see it's
this woman uh with with beautiful red
hair
and they she's in like a like beautiful
cocktail dress
and they're pulling her out of the back
seat of this uh Mercedes and I'm the
only one on the street and they clearly
don't see me but this woman sees me and
she makes like Direct
eye contact with me and they're pulling
her out of the side they're pulling her
out of the back seat she's not fighting
them but she's not helping them either
she's just like completely limp and just
being dragged they take her over to this
building and they just start like
opening her head up against the side of
this building they start smashing her
head so I like forgot where I was and
like I ran at this guy and I grabbed him
and in English I'm like man what the
[ __ ] are you doing what are you doing
and
he just pulled out a gun he just put it
like right to my forehead and he said in
English he's like go away like that and
and and
you know Joe I knew like in an instant
man I knew in an instant that like it
was like I was a bug like I was a bug
like that was a different you know I met
I'd seen guns before I'd seen stuff
before I just knew that this was a
completely different level and so you
know I walked away listening to that
listening to what they're doing and and
I was like day three so that's on the
brutality side of it but I think
conversely on the on on the beauty side
of it
you know there was just it was
it was it was a culture that I found
like completely full free of pretension
you know if you have a conversation with
somebody you really have a conversation
conversation you look in the eye and
there's no hey how you doing hey I'm
doing great there's no [ __ ]
um it wouldn't be strange or weird for
to have somebody break down in tears in
your first meeting and talking to them
and not because they're sort of like
emotionally fragile or weak but because
they're just so honest and in the moment
um I I I I saw this unbelievable
National appreciation for the Arts uh I
I saw
people who uh you know you go on the
Subways and and people weren't reading
you know US Weekly they were reading
bulgalkov and Tolstoy it's an
unbelievable unbelievably literate uh
Society
um
yeah I don't know man I'm I'm I'm so
grateful for my time there and um it
yeah it really you know all my and that
place really really saved my life